bonjour eric coquerel merci d'être avec
nous en direct ce matin sur rtl france
alors votre réaction il ya le procès ce
matin de cet individu qui en farine et
jean luc mélenchon faut-il une sentence
exemplaire selon vous sentance normal
proportionnelle ou fait mais
effectivement c'est bien qu'ils aient eu
huit plaintes déposées ne fait pas
beaucoup mais par l'état parce que c'est
la manifestation qui était visé le droit
de manifestation et je pense que là
aujourd'hui cette fois là c'est la
farine jean luc mélenchon l'a vu à côté
lui menti qu'un jour ça sera autre chose
moi j'étais en farine et une fois par le
même genre de l'individu c'est l'action
d'extrême de de l'action d'actions
françaises organisées contre moi j'avais
porté plainte parce que j'estimais que
il le disait d'ailleurs sur l'heureux
sur leur facebook
la prochaine fois ça pourrait être autre
chose donc voilà il faut mettre un coup
d'arrêt et dire qu'on tolère pas le fait
que le droit de manifester soit soit en
france empêcher merci on verra dans quel
sens quel verdict a été prononcé dans
quelques minutes maintenant eric
coquerel on va parler de la vaccination
qui fait beaucoup de débats en ce moment
la vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants voyez ce qu'on a dit amélie de
montchalin hier c'est difficile de
trancher
écoutez la priorité c'est les soignants
je suis favorable à la vaccination
obligatoire pour les soignants mais pour
qu'il y est obligations il faut qu'il y
ait loi alors est-ce qu'il faut
légiférer selon eric coquerel pour ans
dans sa nature parce qu'ils gênent
beaucoup dans tout ça c'est que comme on
a pas encore longtemps et on devrait
encore le faire d'ailleurs
on était tous à nos balcons et l'état en
premier pour remercier nos souhaits et
là on les pointe du doigt comme les
vecteurs premier de la contamination
voilà je trouve que c'est indécent déjà
un sas et redescend ensuite la deuxième
chose c'est que j'aimerais qu'on me
prouve qu'à partir du moment où je crois
que c'est à peu près 30% dans les
chiffres noirs sont pas certains de
soignants de ne veulent pas c'est un
accident le pays où pour l'instant ne
sont pas vaccinés fort et qu'on prouve
que c'est eux le vecteur le plus
important alors que c'est une profession
est par essence est très protégé
respecte les gestes barrière fait
énormément de tests pcr rien objecté en
course et la communication de façon à
mettre à oschersleben blochet c'est
l'expérience ça se fait pas et de façon
à cacher une impréparation par rapport
aux 91 quatrième vague que ce soit
l'organisation la suite engouement que
ce soit moi ce que je propose depuis
longtemps c'est à dire que l'état
souhaite non nous ne comptons pas nous
contraignent les gens à s'isoler mais il
faut un contraintes posées des
conditions matérielles pour que les gens
puissent isoler ce qu'ils à tout l
inverse de la question posée par castex
et puis par exemple face à grand plan
d'urgence pour les hôpitaux parce que le
rappelle que le problème qui reste
entier toujours c'est qu'on a toujours
peur que le seuil de lits disponibles
soient dépassées et on n'a rien fait
depuis un an ou quasiment rien fait
c'est du lot si une prime c'est une
prime qui ne n'est pas la hauteur du
poème des hôpitaux
voilà évoluer le sabbat ou mais on agite
le problème du vaccin des soignants ça
des gens 4/3 a annoncé la fin du
processus de révision constitutionnelle
sur le climat à écouter
votre assemblée avait décidé de faire un
pas mais cette main tendue n'a pas été
saisie par le sénat ce vote met un terme
au processus constitutionnel qui était
indispensable pour notre pays c'est
regrettable
donc la défense de l'environnement ne
sera pas inscrite dans la constitution à
ce que c'est un coup dur pour emmanuel
macron lui qui avait besoin de verdir un
peu sa politique à quelques mois de la
présidentielle va s'adapter plus servir
de prétexte faut pas faire passer cette
loi mais je vous rappelle qu'on est pas
grand chose dedans quoi on était très
loin avec cette loi de respecter ne
serait-ce que les accords de paris
aujourd'hui vous l'avez la semaine
dernière tous les événements mexique au
canada à chypre en inde
enfin au malheureusement en le golfe du
mexique on est andré la liste
la terre est en train de brûler en ce
moment maintenant c'est pas demain c'est
aujourd'hui que commencent les
événements chaotiques qu'on annonçait et
la france le 2 point de vue là quoi
qu'en dise m à une macro n'est pas du
tout à la pointe de la lutte pour le
climat
elle est très en retard elle a respecté
quasiment aucun d'aider des coups d'épée
aucune des propositions faites par la
convention citoyenne pour le climat en
tout cas les moins importantes et cette
chose assure que cette loi qu'elle était
proposé ne changeait pas grand chose bon
il ya quelques améliorations je
préférerais qu'elle passe quand même
mais franchement c'est c'est rien par
rapport à la situation donc qui même à
krosno cerfs-volistes surtout pas
derrière la décision du sénat nous ce
que nous pensons c'est qu'il faut une
planification écologique de la société
c'est-à-dire non pas le dirigisme
mais faire en sorte que l'état a dit qu
al capp puisse s'appuyer sur des
services publics forts de façon
justement respecter ce que nous avons la
règle au vert le plus consommé produire
ce que la terre puisque la terre ne peut
absorber et là on en était loin avec
cette loi
parmi les lois en débat en ce moment il
y à aussi la loi sur les retraites qui
devrait revenir sur le devant de la
scène
emmanuel macron a reçu les partenaires
sociaux hier est ce qu'il faut en
remettre cette loi en marche
non bien sûr c'est une folie je posais
la question hier au gouvernement en
question
sans les j'ai pas compris la réponse de
madame bornes
pourquoi il faut pas d'abord je vous
rappelle que c'est juste un engagement
du chef de l'état le candidat l'avait
dit le chef de l'état l'a dit en avril
je m'y étais engagé joe jeunes
rallongerait pas l'âge légal de la
retraite
on dirait la réforme parfois le faisait
sans dire mais la grande part points
même eux estiment si j'ai bien compris
que elle ne sera pas mise mise à l'ordre
du jour avant un éventuel deuxième
paquet d'avants voilà il faut pas tout
emmanuel macron élire jean luc mélenchon
qui pour la retraite à 60 ans soit dit
en passant
la deuxième raison pour lesquelles il
faut pas aller là dessus c'est que ça
sert à rien le core logo qui est chargé
d'étudier la cible à l'avenir des
retraites explique en 2070 ce qu'on sera
à nouveau à l'équipe largement des
retraites les retraites elle pèse
toujours moins cher dans la danse est
notable entre la question c'est pas les
dépenses et pas de rallonger l'âge légal
de la retraite
au contraire c'est les recettes l'an
dernier 18 milliards de déficit pourquoi
presque il ya des exonérations par
exemple du chômage partiel deux
explorations ont été donnés il ya eu des
pertes d'emploi ou avec la question
c'est l'emploi nous nous pensons qu'ils
fourniront petit du plein emploi par le
partage du temps de travail il ça
commence surtout par ne pas rallonger
l'âge de départ légal à la retraite ce
qui ce qui en plus qu un non sens d'un
point de vue santé vous avez comme moi
que entre 60 et 64 ans vous avez deux
fois plus de chances d yves pardon des
hospitalisés qu'avant on s'invente
revient qu'à partir de cet âge là vous
êtes fragile et ben c'est le logeant
justement c'est pas de nous tuer au
travail à partir de là alors on a vu
cette réforme des retraites qui va
revenir peut-être sur le devant de la
scène et emmanuel macron doit prendre la
parole avant le 14 juillet eric coquerel
vous vous êtes député il y avait un
texte à l'étude en ce moment à
l'assemblée et ça a fait grincer
certains de vos confrères regarder un
agenda un peu mieux maîtrisée aurait
permis de travailler mieux
le premier ministre et le président de
la république n'ont jamais été
parlementaire et ça se sent j'y vois un
manque d'expérience est la traduction de
ce mépris que le chef de l'état a pour
le parlement comment est-ce que vous
vous abordez ce trop-plein de réformes
je suis d'accord avec cette remarque
s'est retrouvé ses battants le problème
de faire travailler l'assemblée c'est
surtout le fait qu' on sert tous les
errements des textes comme le calendrier
très contraint on a eu deux énormes en
taxes est ce qu'on appelle du temps
partagé ci a besoin de tentes on dévale
par exemple donc moins de temps pour
l'assemblée et savante effectivement un
mépris alors qui est le principe de la
vème république mes mails macro la
exacerbé de manière amplifiée il faut
pas voir c'est une des raisons mon avis
de l'abstention des élections dans
quelques années
donc voila moi ce que j'en crois
vis-à-vis de ces textes qui plus est
justement que qu'une s'aventure parents
plus à alourdir l'assemblée avec
d'autres textes j'ai cru comprendre
qu'ils imaginaient une folie à la
rentrée qui serait de remettre les
articles qui avait été censuré par le
conseil d'état sur la voie s'il était
global sur les drones qui avait la
surveillance généralisée sur le plu aux
devoirs la police municipale exercice
comprendre qu'il voulait leur mettre
dans une loi la rentrée qu'ils arrêtent
voilà qu'ils arrêtent de de mettre en
tension de pays et de effectivement
d'acculer des lois uniquement pour soi
montrer à bruxelles qu'ils appliquent
une loi sur les retraites parce que
c'est ça la question soit encore même
des débats sécuritaires et identitaires
sur la place publique eric coquerel
dernière question évidemment il y à
cette question sur la primaire pour les
parties on l'a vu ce que ça a donné hier
pour les républicains
qu'en est-il à à gauche on l'a entendu
les français s'exprimer sur cette
question jean luc mélenchon serait un
obstacle à l'union de la gauche c'est ce
qu'a dit à catherine d'elgar regarder il
y à une dérive de jean luc mélenchon
depuis plusieurs années jean luc
mélenchon n'est plus de gauche quand on
est de gauche on ne peux pas accréditer
les tests du complotisme sait comment ça
va se passer à gauche c'est une
spécialiste des albums elle va avec les
docks policiers les factieux manifester
ce qui est très républicain ce qui est
très à gauche vraiment elle devrait
s'interroger et je te passe les détails
sur les mesures qu'elle prend sa région
qui ont
pour tous du libéralisme aérienne gauche
puis je vous rappelle qu'elle avait été
comme très proche de sous thèmes
acrocime du monde celle là paf pour bref
ces gens là vous savez c'est leur
problème
c'est n'ont jamais supporté france a
soumises deviennent les supplante leur
programme social libéral voilà c'est moi
je crois que depuis 2010 est la leur
lors ambition leur volonté c'est de
revenir à la case départ au parti
socialiste et hégémonie qui donnait
françois hollande qui nous a ensuite
donné emmanuel macron et quitte à perdre
parce que quand vous disais un deuxième
tour quand vous dites que vous voulez
gagner l'élection
je vous assure vous injuriez pas
l'avenir les électeurs qui pourraient
vous soutenir vous soutenir vous agiriez
pas les électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
tous à mon avis c'est de manière très
sectaire et ça montre après tout s'il ps
redevenez justement majorité oh quel
serait l'avenir de cette gauche là c'est
vraiment pas terrible
en tout cas de ces gens là au ps et bien
d'autres peut-être qu'ils avaient qui on
peut travailler
moi je le fait que le système se posent
à nous j'allais dire c'était presque un
sourcing savons que s'il ya bien eu un
candidat est une formation qui dans ce
pays proposent une vraie alternative au
système avec la planification écologique
la 6ème république le partage des
richesses partage du temps de travail
l'indépendantiste au niveau politique
extérieure la rupture des tripes turpin
et bien c'est nous voilà c'est la mort
raisons pour lesquelles dans la vie que
ce soit le système du côté de la droite
du système du côté des sociaux libéraux
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui est visé
mais on fera sans fera sans eux et on
fera si c'est nécessaire contre eux
voilà on s'aperçoit dresse au port ses
idées notre eurent beau pull et merci
beaucoup merci eric coquerel d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt france